i went to vegas this past week
yep
and
so i was already kind of nervous going
in you know i was reading all these
headlines like the the mayor or governor
of hawaii said if there's a place you
shouldn't go you absolutely should not
go to las vegas yeah i saw that part of
me said hey man
kick rocks you're j this is just travel
envy you're just upset
more people are said
fine i'll go to reno
oh nothing's keeping me from those
[ __ ] slot machines baby oh you think
oh you think vegas is the problem catch
me in laughlin dude
i'll go to laughlin
laughlin what the [ __ ] is that you never
heard of laughlin bro no
that's like
that's like um
a gold mining town where kids were bred
and then they were told the rest of the
earth
like doesn't exist
oh i see no this one's old
i guarantee if we go there right now
there's a guy in um
in a civil war uniform still that his
grandparents gave him and he's sitting
in a slot machine right now
playing in those clothes
he still thinks the war is going
[Laughter]
we win yeah he's waiting for a telegram
or something to come through to let him
know that he can
you know retire from duty
uh
so
i'm trying to i'm trying to ignore
everything
and then
my car was acting a little bit weird i
got some strange
error well i'll put it like this
car's acting like a little funky because
the air conditioning was randomly just
like not working very well so i was
thinking uh maybe i'm running it too low
this is kind of strange
and then
as i'm driving
um i start i get this message that says
like uh electrical system malfunction
and that just sounded scary so i'm in
the middle of traffic i haven't really
left la yet and i i get off the freeway
and i'm going to pull over
and
while i'm trying to figure this out i
call a dealership and i say hey i'm like
right by i'm getting this weird error
can i bring the car by they say yeah
sure
so i'm heading towards that dealership
and as i'm driving
i start getting tons of errors and
things just start turning off you know
first it's my radio and then it's this
and then the ac and then my power
steering and then my braking system and
then my transmission turns off and then
i get this thing that's like caution car
will roll away and as all this is
happening i'm gently like trying to slow
the car down
and i can't throw it in park so i like
uh
basically i crank the wheel and i push
it against like a curb and then i'm
pulled over
get out the car
i'm thinking what the hell
just got this thing
the [ __ ] and then i open telegram and
then you go i just tested positive for
covet
oh yeah
and then i'm sitting there with elena
siva and his girl
i'm thinking
did i just like infect everybody so now
i'm sketched out i'm like
uh i need to go get a test how do i get
there
this and
that was a place 15 minutes walking
distance and i was too sketched to like
order an uber so i say [ __ ] it
i just walk
in the heat
as they wait for the car to get like
picked up
okay so i get tested i'm negative cool
go to get the car
my car is still at that dealership
there's this whole thing
is this the car that you recently got
yeah
ah that's soft so i got like a lemon
part it was like the alternator went out
so it was like really odd whatever
um i think it'll be fixed by friday
you know whatever
that was like you know i got that
happened things are going wrong like
yeah yeah yeah but at that you got the
covet scare your car's broken down and
now i'm freaking out about las vegas um
and i'm thinking okay like something bad
is gonna happen sweet whatever so
um i'm saying all this because i want to
tell you
you know by the way guys gambling is
horrible
yeah exactly don't go
pre uh just as a precursor here don't
gamble you will lose your money now
back to what i was saying so as i'm
waiting for the car to get fixed i'm on
the rubik mobile app and
i'm just joking i'm just joking
and so
you know all this happens we go to like
there's like a crazy rental car shortage
we go to get a rental car the only thing
i could get is like this ram truck
okay sick and we put all our luggage in
the in the back and we're driving into a
straight-up storm so there's this 50-50
chance that all our clothes and [ __ ] are
gonna get rained out it just it's just
feeling like a bad trip
we get there
you know
one day goes by
lose a little bit of money on slots you
know like i maybe threw 100 bucks in
there i'm like all right maybe this just
isn't the weekend
but going there siva was like
i don't know man i still got a good
feeling i think i think we're going to
hit it big
by the way guys see this is why you
don't play slots because you're down
you're down 100 bucks you said yeah okay
so don't play slots don't oh go ahead
with yourself don't ever play slots so i
put in 200 the next day okay okay
i get wrecked immediately
[Laughter]
it's not even no but
what
okay sorry keep going
but you know it's it's not even fair get
my ass kicked
okay and
now i'm hurt i'm thinking this really
isn't my weekend i just you know it's
now i'm 300 bucks in the hole i'm like
what the [ __ ] am i doing
and so then steve was kind of you know
he's going up and down a little bit
we go we go have dinner
we
we go back to the machines and we get on
this machine you ever play this machine
uh revenge attack like invaders from the
planet moolah return of the evaders from
planet mule it's the weirdest slot
machine ever
it's really dope the art is really cool
gambling is really bad by the way the
art is really cool the premise of the
slot is really interesting
it's like watching like a tv show it's
like it's it's fun but gambling's awful
yeah don't do it so i'm playing and i
look over to seva
and he hits a bonus and it's going
higher
and higher like under the free spin
amount if you never played a slot
basically
every slot machine you want to hit three
of like a special symbol and it'll give
you free spins and then
you know
whatever
uh
you hopefully win some money
so i text cody while this is happening
and
siva's free spins are some absurd number
it's like 50 or 60
and is it gets up to 500 bucks i'm like
this dude has 75 free spins left and
he's already at 500 this is crazy
i can't i've never witnessed someone
like i've never known someone to win
like this have you have you ever like
been with someone who's once okay
yeah i've been that guy oh how much have
you won what's the
like the first the first time that sam
and i played
uh the slot that we like it was hitting
like that okay we were like we would get
these bonuses
that would result in like 500 spins it
was crazy okay and so we got up to like
1500 bucks or something like wow we put
in like 100 or something wow all at once
or was it like a yeah okay oh it was
like over the course like four hours
okay okay so yeah we were just
degenerate sitting there like
doing stupid [ __ ] sure well i guess
yeah so i've never
i've never stood next to someone was one
that much of a slot machine but
especially not in one hand
so it's it's starting to like count up
it's getting to 700 and then he hits
more free spins on top of like there's
50 left and he goes back up to 70. i'm
like what is happening
this thing goes all the way to thirteen
hundred dollars and he wins a jackpot
and everyone around him is like
whoa
like
this one lady dog she was down in the
hole so bad and i could just see like
how hurt she was watching this [ __ ] so
okay cool like he wins the jackpot
it's this whole thing they make him come
out sign a paper they have to once it's
over twelve hundred dollars they have to
pay it out to you in person which i
thought was really interesting
and the way they paid out to you is so
like
it's just so funny they go hold out your
hands sir and they make you put your
hand like this so they can count it so
you can see the money
so i'm like wow congratulations you hit
it big dude you did exactly what you
said you were going to do hold on that
money
we go to sleep wake up whatever we wake
up we have breakfast
i'm like if he won
come on man i got it just like i got to
get at least get my money back
so i throw 100 that kid i'm [ __ ] i'm
400 in that like a dumbass and i'm
getting worked i go to vanna i'm like
vanna do me right
vana takes a fat [ __ ] right on my face
you're talking about wheel of fortune
yeah
okay okay i'm like what is wrong with
you lady she
[Laughter]
you [ __ ]
yeah i'm cussing i thought you were cool
yeah i'm cussing her out
and as i'm playing i look over because
siva calls my name he goes no well i'm
like look
and he he he goes like this with his
hands
i'm like
this [ __ ] this [ __ ]
what what was that was it did i just see
1300
we walk over
his girl hit a jackpot
on a different machine and she hit it
within like five minutes of sitting down
jesus christ
so are you fuming at this no i'm happy
for them i'm like they flew in they they
won this money that's [ __ ] awesome
i'm getting my eyes jealous as [ __ ] i
would have been envious i mean yeah of
course i'm jealous but like
i would have been
zero percent happy i would have been
happy on the surface for them wow nice
job
so proud of you guys
wow that's really cool that you won
oh yeah oh yeah so great
nothing
ah it's so cool when the machine doesn't
bend you over and [ __ ] you
it's really cool for you though i'm
super happy
so
uh they win and he continues to just hit
these little strides where he's making a
little more here make a little more
there
and
you know so i guess now i'm for just to
cap it off i go i'm 400 deep on slots
there's there's no way
the poker room was way too packed and
after you tested positive i was really
sketched out on being that close to
people because they took the plastic
bank teller visors out so i'm like i'm
okay
so
i go you know what
blackjack right
yeah that's that's gonna work out right
yeah uh-huh
no no you got slammed i put 300 in
and the casino just
sucked me off
like chloe yeah
hi i'd like to play
they shouldn't even they shouldn't even
like let you put it down on the table
you know what i'm saying it should just
be a vacuum like a tube like in willy
wonka
that augustus gloop goes up or whatever
yeah
it should be one of those and you just
put the it goes it's just constantly
yeah
i can't breathe i have the lung capacity
of a small baby right now
yeah and it goes up to the casino yeah
and then and then they give you an ipad
with a cocoa melon video that's 30
minutes long and you just watch that
yeah you just turn your brain to mush
and then you put in another 300 and you
watch another coco melon video
and then the dealer just stands there
and they're like you want to hit you
want to stay
i would l i would love another hit
[Music]
yeah and it goes straight up to this
room
with a bunch of dudes
who are drinking champagne and just
looking out the window
and you see the money just flying in the
air all around them
yeah they're just in a gigantic
money telephone booth like those things
that they
used to put at carnivals where they're
like grab a hundred dollars
yeah it's all singles in there
yeah
so yeah i figured you'd enjoy a good uh
double jackpot story that i thought that
was crazy just two jackpots oh yeah
that's and how fun was it uh
so fun do you finally understand the the
beauty of slots like when it's working
oh not only it can be so much fun yeah
not only that i
i i hit a point where i
i crossed over that threshold what the
hell oh hold on i hit that threshold you
know when you start to like it a little
too much
you know and i'm like i'm like starting
to quote the slot machine
[Laughter]
that's the best and then you get into
like the lore yeah and like the world
you you kind of start to be a character
in the world yeah you know yeah like
you're interacting with this like we
only do nautical themed one now once or
ocean themed at least right so like
anything to do with fish like we'll play
that okay so there's layers that's kind
of like our like we we see ourselves as
kind of the like gambling merman
so there's layers gambling merman who
else who else besides larry you know
what there's some other ones in reno
that we're not in reno but in uh tahoe
that we were playing that were random
just like
[ __ ] just no name i don't even know
what they were ocean master five
or something slot machines from the 80s
yeah there's still a difference still a
dude from the mob who has to come by and
manually collect on them
yeah
got a bowler hat ash and cigarettes out
in it
your time on this one's almost over boys
it's time to collect
you